yeah so for the next talk we have ketan
who is the founder and CEO at Union Ai
and also creator of flight and on the
other hand we have Yi who is also
founding engineer at unionia in flight
so let's give them a round of applause
and welcome
[Applause]
hello uh am I audible everywhere yeah
hi uh thank you for coming and I know
this is noon uh hopefully you I'll vet
your appetite for the food I saw outside
I saw sushi that looked amazing
uh
so what are we here to talk about but
before that let me introduce who am I
why am I talking about this stuff so my
name is ketan I'm the CEO and co-founder
at Union but mostly an engineer 18 years
and the two unhappy thoughts over there
in that meet in that photo are my kids
uh mostly spending time with them
nowadays uh in my free time when I'm not
building Union
we also have e with us who's a founding
engineer at Union a co-founder and
loves he writes most of the code in
flight and you'll often see him hanging
out in the open source Channel including
me so if you are on slack.flight.org say
hi to us
uh in a previous life he was a he was
writing strategy pieces at a mortgage
Tech desk where he switched his career
and now he's a rust Lang programmer or
wannabe
what are we here to talk about
uh any guesses
llms of course
and now we are at Pi data ecosystem we
are here to talk about the ecosystem and
and the problems in utilizing
this diverse amazing ecosystem of tools
and technologies that we're building
within the pi data world
but there are you know
if you see the number of tools you'll
see that there are a lot of problems
right and and we want to find the
solution today
and the way we'll do this is we'll work
together
and we'll use like first principles to
try and come up with a solution
we'll share an existing implementation
of such a solution we think it's flight
and then of course if you hang with me
throughout this
throughout this you know next 30 minutes
I promise you I'll show you something
about llms
one thing I will show you is that llms
does not need you to be a math major
it's really a
data problem and we are at Pi data so
the right problem to solve here
so let's talk about the problems right
problem one
if you ever see an orchestra
is everybody a guitar player no
is everybody a violin player no
some of them are guitar players some
play Trumpets and you want that you want
that Harmony that Symphony
in an organization such as the case
sometimes you have
guys were great at spark folks who are
great at
you know no data science some folks who
know deep learning now some people who
know NLP
and
the symphony the orchestra of an
organization happens when all of them
work together
so but there are like a lot of these
different people do you how do you kind
of make them work together
one solution oftentimes that people
think about is let's make everything be
the same let's use the same set of tools
for everybody
well that doesn't really work right if
you let's say you choose a csvs as your
only default way of sharing data it's
pretty inefficient is
for storing columnar data are like like
many many orders of magnitude faster
more efficient and not just easier to
use if you use the right tools
secondly right you know we data frames
are all the rage all the time for the
last few years there are lots of data
frame Technologies I it cannot even put
them on a slide this is from polaris's
website so maybe it looks a little
tainted towards Polaris but the goal was
to show that for certain problem sets
it's important to use the right
technology if you don't use the right
technology you end up skewing in
performance Dimensions Effectiveness
efficiency uh and and many other
dimensions that you know some tools are
better at
the third problem is what I call the
problem of overhead
you know every time I try to write
something I end up doing this
boilerplate stuff right like look at
this code I I was just trying to say
like let me run
and actually boost training task maybe
it's wrong even but uh
instead of focusing on that I was like
where do I how do I get my data there
how do I load that data how do I convert
the file how do I write the model how do
I store the model
and really the only interesting part
over here was these two lines about 90
percent of this code is useless
and that's overhead
so now we know these three problems how
do we solve them but before that
let's use the first principles approach
to solving the problem what do we know
as computer Engineers right we know that
there is software
afterwards are called programs program
sticks input produce an output right
in machine learning
there are programs that take features
now these features have different
definitions in different contexts
the program itself is called The
Learning algorithm or the modeling
technique or the neural network or the
regressor or like you know different
names for them
and the final output is actually the
model
right this is the machine learning
context
but the features themselves where do
they come from or the model actually
this is if you have a model you take the
features to produce predictions on them
right that's a downstream activity that
you've done on a model
similarly the features
were actually derived from some raw data
you have the data probably in Snowflake
and data breaks and data lakes and Delta
lakes and like hundreds of different
Technologies you want to take that and
make it into usable artifacts those are
called features
and a machine learning product is not
one of these things it's all of it put
together right you can only derive
business value when you put all of them
together into one box
so let's use this first principles
approach and apply it to a real world
problem
I'm a machine learning engineer data
scientist who wants to write
a training algorithm I want my model I I
really don't care about the
infrastructure right I just like I want
to write this code
I don't care about gpus but
interestingly I need gpus to work with
so
in my in my ideal world I want to put a
comment saying
this code should run on a GPU
maybe one maybe eight maybe 16 I don't
know the number
but I need data and I go around and ask
somebody it's like hey I can write this
data for you
I know how to do spark
so this this other guy helps me he's
like hey I'm gonna write this cool code
on spark it's going to take terabytes of
data and finally featurize everything
and maybe the eventual data set is only
two gigabytes enough to load in memory
and I can train a model
but but that person now has to somehow
inform the system
that I should be using spark right let's
assume there's this amazing way of
writing a comment on it that says yeah
let's use Spark
eventually that's not enough right you
built a model what do you do with it you
want to publish like you want to do some
Downstream activities with it publish it
to hugging face or run predictions on
them or deploy it somewhere right
and oftentimes what we find is like
you've all seen chat GPT and or GitHub
co-pilot and all these cool amazing
models these are massive models they
cannot run on even one machine right
they're that big so how do you make them
run so you do various things like
quantization but sometimes you want to
do things like evaluation like make sure
that the model is right doing the right
thing it's not biased it's correct it's
actually solving the problem that I
expected to solve it's not degrading the
performance then what the current model
that's out there doing
and then you may want to optimize the
model itself for various tasks
so this is my total you know I derive
the same first principles Approach at a
real world problem
but what if there was a system that
would allow me to convert
these comments that I put in
and just replace them with like a a
pythonic way of doing Thomas like a
decorator
and I could do the same for my gpus I
could say I want eight gpus and I want
you to elastically scale this this model
that I've built because I don't know how
to do
really work with 8 gpus but I want you
to elastically scale this into 8 gpus
what we call this is declarative
infrastructure right it comes from IAC
infrastructure as code and like this
other devops domain that has been
working in this space for a while
instead of writing so there are two
aspects Happening Here one is
you express your intent
along with the express of what you want
to do right so the what was your program
in the intent that you wanted to run on
GPU
the other thing that happens over here
is it is actually coupled with your code
so as your code evolves you can evolve
your expectations from the
infrastructure for example today you
don't need GPU you are using XG boost
tomorrow you need GPU you can add GPU
today you need one GPU then you need
eight gpus and then we a 100 you finally
get an a100 on AWS almost impossible to
get by the way uh you get one a100
yeah like I don't need eight gpus I just
need one GPU again right so you you
should be able to evolve your
requirements as things change and the
what is the best way to do this we use
git we love git we put code in Gate why
not put it next to it
so now
what did this end up becoming we need a
system that's like taking a person's
brain or the ideas from his eye brain
allowing him to use the technology that
he wants to write like the code or
whatever and it is taking and doing the
boilerplate part of it like translating
communicating you abstracting the low
level infrastructure and then getting
both these people working on the same
fabric
so such a system needs to have some
special properties and these properties
are as I think at least
are that it needs to be a central fabric
you don't want every team to reinvent
the same thing again and again and again
and again right you want a center fabric
and and when I say reinvent it's not
only reinvention in terms of
creating the same technology or
rewriting the new technology even using
an existing technology for every team
again and again is hard for example I'll
tell you like if you spark if I tell
every team to say like okay you will all
use Spark from tomorrow
they will all be like okay how do I
start a spark cluster where do I start
it and that's where companies come in
where they start selling your spark
clusters Etc and that's the business
right
second part is declarative
infrastructure abstraction we I think I
have impressed all of you guys on the
idea that this is needed
third one is data aware
and data aware here means and we'll talk
more uh when he talks more about it but
data aware here means that I understand
what you're trying to do what you're
trying to communicate and I will take
the boilerplate away
extensibility
because we just talked about the number
of amazing tools we should be just
applicable to almost all tools we should
be able to handle them
and then finally above all of this it
needs to be simple to use if it's not
simple to use nobody will use it and you
will not be able to get your
organization to you know you know take
this over
so
we've been working in open source and
we've seen a lot of companies get this
right
it's it's taken some time it's been
happening over the last few years
and their secret at least we think they
use things this thing called as flight
which is a great segue into
ye coming over and sharing what is
flight
thank you very much kitten
so we just to recap we've
talked about the problem we've reasoned
about how we think we should solve the
problem and we've hinted at what a
solution at least should theoretically
look like so what is flight flight is in
essence our solution to that problem and
we believe if it's not the correct
solution is at least a correct solution
flight was born out of uh issues that
were encountered by the ml engineers and
data scientists on the ETA team while at
Lyft this is Circa 2015 and as we solve
those problems other teams came in with
their own use cases and as we solved
those problems other teams came in and
what you now see as flight is actually
the third incarnation of the platform
throughout that time we realized many
lessons one of which was
data scientists and ml Engineers don't
care about
infrastructure they care about the
little
Black Box in the top left corner they
care about their business logic they
care about their code and they want
enough resources to run their code but
they don't care about pods They Don't
Care About Auto scaling groups and they
they definitely don't care about the the
correct annotations to put on your
reverse proxy to get grpc Ingress to
work that's just not in their domain so
what is flight flight is the system that
allows them to not think about any of
those things and only think about their
code so flight will handle things like I
O it'll handle caching it will handle
versioning
it will handle spinning up gpus
they will handle spinning up spot nodes
when you need them
so that is that is flight at a high
level
the next one so at a high level that is
stepping down uh let's talk about the
individual components of tasks of of
flight the executable units and then
we'll hop into a few examples so what is
a task a task is the atomic unit of work
in flight and it's not a coincidence
that this looks like the slide that
Caitlyn presented earlier you have some
inputs you have some business logic and
you have some outputs so all tasks in
flight are strongly typed and they're
all versioned and they all have an
interface
uh the Little Whale there most tasks are
containerized so there is a container
that will run the business logic not all
tasks are the canonical example of a
non-container type business logic is
like a SQL task so if you run a
snowflake query and you dump the output
to a Blog store somewhere like S3 or GCS
or bigquery that is a non-containerized
task
uh
what does it workflow
a workflow is a series of tasks put
together into a data flow so dataflow is
a first class citizen
similar to tasks they have an input they
have an output they're strongly typed
and they are versioned
um and forgot to mention both tasks and
workflows are locally executable
so
you can run them and iterate on your
code on the machine on your laptop
before sending them off to the platform
there's a Code snippet here and you
don't need to look too closely but the
the point of this snippet is that
workflows you declare them in Python and
they look very much like python they're
not it's not quite actually python is
more of a pythonic DSL
so there there's a slight difference
workflow code is run at compile time so
at compile time when you tell the system
you want to run when you give flights
your your business logic it will run the
body of the workflow function
uh the body of your task functions are
run at runtime so that's an important
point to distinguish
one of the questions just a quick aside
one of the questions that we see often
when people start using flight is how do
I like I'm coming with like this repo
how do I
um how do I know what to split out into
tasks and workflows and such and the the
answer there is a good guideline to
start with at the very least is think
about your resources so obviously if you
have a a chunk of code that is like very
memory intensive and doesn't need gpus
and another chunk of code that is very
GPU intensive then obviously those are
natural boundaries and that tends to be
pretty good guideline and that people
tend to get the hang of where to split
uh how to split their code pretty pretty
quickly
um there's one more element that I want
to introduce and that's a launch plan
like launch plans it's inputs and
there's a workflow there's an output
it's strongly typed so a launch plan is
just
a thin wrapper around workflows when you
run a workflow you're not actually
running the workflow you're running a
launch plan every workflow comes with a
default launch plan and the reason for
this is just because our users came to
us and said we have one launch plan but
we have many different ways we want to
run it we want to write the outputs to a
different bucket we want to run with a
different service account we want to run
on a schedule we want to run these
schedules on different on different
input default inputs so you can run
certain inputs on Monday and then like
you can have a Saturday execution but
because it's the weekend you make you
run it on slot instances right so some
stuff like that
and soon you'll be able to customize and
override the resources within the
workflow as well
so these are the executable elements of
flights how do you bring everything
together as we alluded to you bring them
together with a strong type system
so everything in Flight comes every all
the communication within flight
and all the communication between the
user and flight happens through a
strongly typed system
so this is how we give compile time
guarantees so if you have the output of
a spark task and you want to give it to
a task that expects a hugging phase
model then you'll get a compile time
error before any of your code is run and
this is something that will if my pie
doesn't catch it will will help you save
time
the the workflows are also the primary
entry point for most users is the python
SDK there is also a jvm SDK for people
to use
uh but with so
the system because it is so strongly
typed
does take away some flexibility
in order to give flexibility back to the
user we make all parts of flight but
especially task types and types
themselves very very easy to extend so
these are some of the Integrations that
people have written so all it takes is
for one person one time to write
uh
a little bit of code that teaches flight
how to translate between your type and
the flight system and that is enough to
unlock the rest of the flight ecosystem
for that type so it's it's pretty simple
if you squint closely also you'll see
that the last the last method here is
called two HTML we'll discuss that later
but you can you can describe like how
you want that to look on a web page
so these are the brief introduction to
brief introduction to flight let's jump
to a couple examples
this is not the resolution I'm used to
so
uh
let's see here so I'm going to walk
through the code very briefly and then
these were toy examples but they they
touch on the features and flexibility of
flight and they also mimic pretty well a
lot of the techniques and methods that a
data scientists would use on a
day-to-day basis so what we went through
the code real quick and then show what
the UI looks like
so this is the workflow we're going to
score some images
uh this this is a task it will display
them we'll render we'll do some
pre-processing and then we'll render out
a quality report
for members of the audience
pretty much everyone here probably knows
this pattern this just implies that it
is locally executable so you can run
this locally and iterate on this and
even view the rendered report
um
so let's we're going to run through the
code real quick just to
just to keep everyone on the same page
uh there's nothing special here so score
image is pretends to score an image
there's only two lines that I want to
highlight first as we alluded to earlier
is it is decorated this tells flight
that this is a task this is one of these
Atomic units of work
and then we pass it a couple options we
turn on an opt-in feature
and then the other that is special is
that opt-in feature you'll see that we
we call this we run this thing called a
deck this is a flight deck this is an
HTML page that comes with every task
execution and it's just a prettier way
for users to visualize what happened
during that task users are responsible
for putting in the elements that they
want but it comes flight kit comes with
renderers that will take various types
or your pre-declared HTML override and
put things together in a web page for
you
um
from there I want to jump to this task
this is a little bit special
um
a dynamic task is so a workflow the body
of a workflow code is run at compile
time the body of a task code is run at
runtime on the cluster a dynamic task is
halfway in between each of those it is a
workflow that is compiled at runtime how
do you know when you need to use this if
you think to yourself I want to run a
workflow but I don't I'm not going to
know the structure of the workflow until
runtime
then you need a dynamic task so you can
do things like if this list of images
here is less than 10 then do one thing
if it's greater than 10 then do
something else right so
that is what a dynamic task is in
essence and here uh we just run a couple
more tasks we convert these images to a
data frame
not necessary but for the point of
demonstration there's no common data
frame fabric really across the python
ecosystem so we had to create one that's
called structure data set you can pass
in any data frame for which there is a
Transformer a type engine
Transformer that we allud to earlier to
the structured data set object
and then we're going to grab its
location and pass it on to a paper mill
task and a paper mill task that looks
like this and this code doesn't do
anything terribly complex
read in the parquet file and then
run some pretty simple logic so that's
all well and good
you have your you have your task that's
great it runs locally that's great
you're pretty confident that it works
how do you get this to the flight system
so the act of getting it to the flight
system is registration
and
when you register three things happen
First Flight will go through your code
and extract out all the all the tasks
and workflows and launch plans all the
components will compile them will ship
them off to the server
and it will make sure that the inputs
and outputs match and if they don't
match then you'll get a friendly error
the second thing that it does is that we
realized that
people users change their code way way
more frequently than they change their
underlying the underlying requirements
right so they build their images with
new tip requirements maybe once every
two weeks they change their code like
every hour every half hour
so the second thing that this does is by
default and you can turn this off it
will zip up all your code and ship them
off to the blob store associated with
the flight backend at runtime it will
then download that updated side of code
and use that instead
so this think of this as like the last
layer on top of your Docker container
um
this also allows us to run if you do not
if you go back to this to this code here
you'll see that we had to declare a
uh container image if you do not declare
a container image you can you will
default to the default container image
that we provide that just has python
flight kit and a couple other
dependencies and the reason that that's
able to work is because we grab your
code from from the store at runtime
so you can specify a string here you can
give this a string and then it will use
it will associate your task with that
container image if you don't want to
deal with Building images this is a new
feature that we just that we just
launched it is still in beta but you can
declare an image spec so users that
don't want to think about a Docker file
don't have to you just give it the tip
dependencies that you want the apps
dependencies that you want and where to
write it to and it will build
using a again plugable system because
everything in Flight is pluggable
currently we use the tensor code NFD
environment
this will build the image push it and
then associate your tasks with that
image
so what is putting this all together
registering it and running it what does
it look like
of course
you get a
you
get a UI that looks something like this
so notably like for instance this is
where your your deck would have come in
uh these are the rendered images from
the display task that we saw earlier if
this would actually load
yeah
cool so some pretty images again these
are this is fake generated data
um and then like if you were to look at
the the quality report task like this is
the output of a paper mill task so we
just render uh we render the the
notebook in line with its outputs so you
can easily see like what what the task
did
um
and then I want to jump over to one more
example
and that is over here
and
actually let's start with the uh let's
start with the dashboard here so this
one is maybe a little bit more canonical
um I don't know if you just can see this
but uh
start workflow you load some data
process it with some ETL flow again just
all mocked but you can imagine some ETL
process split the data out into training
and validation sets
train the model twice using different
hyper parameters
um
and validate using the validation data
set and then render a performance report
so very canonical classic classic flow
the
the thing I wanted to point out here was
because
if you look closely you'll see a little
dotted line around this box
what that is one of these Dynamic tasks
and the reason we have that is this is
one of those instances when you don't
quite know what you need to run until
until you at runtime when the inputs are
put in by the user so we have some
default inputs here but maybe we do
maybe we don't um if you you can give it
a list of your regularization parameters
and the other special thing I wanted to
point to real quick was this side here
if you don't want to this uses the same
construct if you don't want to manage
your images in the python objects you
can also manage them via yaml file so
this will do the same thing you put in
your
a tip and apps dependencies and will
build and push the image for you to the
destination of your choice
and
we'll take a look at some
we'll take a look at this performance
report here as well
do we not
there you go
so
not much change in this case this is
again a fake example so between the two
the two hyper parameters not much has
changed but
um
certainly they can
so with that I will hand it back over to
cathan to talk about the last example
which as we promised you yeah
thank you
um yeah so uh what what you know he
showed was a
typical way when we started building
flight it was for classical ml
going to XG boost going to deep learning
because that's how we've evolved right
really and even
other AI techniques like operations
research
Logistics you know tuning
most of the companies that users use
flight or use Union use it in production
because when you're building a product
that needs machine learning in
production you want reliability you want
other things right
and and some of the things that we've
not even covered today is uh like
caching and how that optimizes cost Etc
but recently we've talked you've heard a
lot about llms
and you've heard about training nlms
you've heard about in context learning
you've heard about fine tuning all this
like lots of words that are happening
uh
we have a take here basically we think
these models are great they solve a
class of problems and and these problems
last year we thought were not solvable
and then late last year we're like oh
yeah these are all solvable suddenly
right it's just like the the Alex net or
the image
thing that happened in 2012 is happening
with natural language but I think this
is not all of the solutions right there
are like we probably are going to
uncover more and more of these Solutions
so we need a fabric that allows you to
adapt to these changes
and a thing that will happen is you see
all of these large models and people are
trying to do in context learning what
we've also found is that we think
fine-tuning is a very interesting side
of things for
um working with language models
specifically if you're working with
smaller bottles which are much easier to
manage
you want to fine tune them on your data
sets and get responses that are much
more relevant here
so flight ships with uh you can write
your
code using pytharch or tensorflow right
now pytarch and it ships with elastic
touch training so if you are running on
a code and here's the example
of what we did is we actually took some
of the cool new fine tuning uh repos
that are coming up and they're like can
we build one repo that does all of this
and it's reproducible for everybody who
has a kubernetes cluster and flight
installer
and that's what we are doing we're still
still in progress but we are able to do
quite a bit and I'll show you a sneak
peek into some of this
so essentially this is the training task
we we wrote the trainer it uses hugging
face
and we have a construct here called
elastic if you have used starch run or
any of the other ways of running pytouch
that's how you launch a training job
you don't have to launch it you don't
have to know how that works internally
but you just set up the configuration on
a task
this will internally automatically
create the the
multi-gpu training system and you can
set the number of gpus you want in this
case I've set 8 gpus it'll automatically
do set up fsdp if you if so you want
fsdp fully sharded data parallel
training or deep speed
Etc it'll set up all of that and you can
write the code to train it
you can also write another task to push
it publish your models to hugging phase
if so if that's what you wish
um and I'm not going to run it right now
but I'll just jumped to an example of
what we did here's an example we ran
um just a 1 billion parameter model
um
if this loads of course authentication
happens at that time
um
if you if you see what we are saying
that we are using fully sharding in fsdp
but in this in this particular example
we didn't fully utilize the GPU as we
did not have a shared memory setup but
now we do
and we use this one billion parameter
model from hunting face
um and yeah it was trained in 13 minutes
or equal to about four dollars or less
than four dollars for GPU and so you can
train it and this can be trained
directly from a UI so you can take this
code you can go in
change the type of input fields for your
data like you may call input as
instruction or some may call it as
question or so on right and then the
instruction key Etc and and we've we've
defaulted to one data set you can change
this data set to be whatever you want it
can be hugging phase data set it can be
an S3 link it can be an https link
doesn't matter
and then you can specify your fsgp
config if if you want to
and change the name of the model
once you do that it will automatically
run the fine tuning on that model
specifically and we did it for a few
different models in the last couple days
and we train like three models that we
have pushed to hugging face they're all
free to use they're using alpaca it's
nothing new people have been doing this
but the goal here was to show that you
can scale out the same system to do all
of this across multiple different models
and we are working in over the next few
weeks you will see us pushing out one
billion seven billion 64 billion and so
on uh so that's our goal that we wanted
to simplify the axis of fine tuning just
like people are doing in context
learning
let me go back to the I got my 10 minute
warning so I will go back to the slide
deck
um
so that was the demo
we will recap so what we saw is
we we talked about a lot of things right
we talked about the ecosystem itself how
it is evolving how it is
changing and and you need your
organizations need to
instantly adapt to these changes and you
need a fabric that can adapt to those
changes and that's what we showed as an
example being flight it's fully open
source is part of Linux Foundation it's
a top level graduate project I highly
encourage everybody to check out
flight.org
we also showed you you can how you can
build more democratized access to the
techniques like fine-tuning and another
thing that I want to highlight is fine
tuning should not be inaccessible to
most people here like it should be it
should be cheap it should be you know
four dollars in training is not is
doable by most organizations and that's
the power of the open source models in
the open source uh fabric of trading
the last piece that we want to show is
that the community itself is growing we
highly invite everybody here to come and
collaborate and join if you want to do
talks we're happy to help in things
but we did not talk about all the other
problems that happen once you are in
production and that's where flight
actually solves many of them this flight
was built for production how do you
handle multitudency you know
organization how do you handle
production reliability your company now
starts depending on ML and data as a
production artifact right think about
this this is a change in our Behavior
it's not like oh my ETL process did not
run yesterday it's okay let me rerun it
now no if you don't do that you
essentially lose business
this is a critical moment right that
that's what we are saying is very
different set of requirements that are
put on the system how do I reproduce my
results like I like we work with biotech
Pharma companies who are like
I
FDA can come 10 years from now and ask
me to reproduce the results of how you
discovered the antibodies for covet
maybe you know there could be problems
in there ah what about dynamism like how
do you actually change and alter your
behavior based on uh like the core
Behavior based on inputs itself how do I
extend it for my internal infrastructure
like this is the number one problem I
have like 15 different Services already
but
flight doesn't come comes with opinions
but it comes with extensibility so you
should be able to extend and finally how
do I optimize my cost I think the number
one problem this year that we're seeing
many people do is like how do I optimize
how do I use spot machines now how do I
send certain things to smart and it kind
of handles all of that already out of
the gate
so and in the case that you folks are
thinking oh I don't have a team with
kubernetes and devops expertise that's
where Union uh the company that we
started it's actually the stewards of
flight but we also provide a hosted
offering a flight with you know
Enterprise features Etc
and that's it we are open for Q a
thank you thank you Keith and Yi for
this amazing presentation and definitely
that making accessible the llm fine
tuning is going to be very helpful for
individuals as well as the companies so
do we have yeah
thanks for the presentation I am maybe
this is a question that you have got
before I'm not I'm not sure I
when we're looking through the Syntax
for the uh the annotations and this sort
of thing it reminds me of a lot of
python I've seen
um deployed in the Apache airflow system
um which has become very very popular as
well and uh what is
where's the sheer ground here between
flight and and something like airflow
airflow being a general purpose workflow
management system
um and and we
do you have somewhere to go which
directly distinguishes the key
differences and the key benefits of
flight over something like airflow yeah
um great questions let me repeat that
question like I think thank you in
summary what's the differences between
flight and airflow and like we have seen
The Decorator pattern I think
it's kind of weird thing to say but we
probably Started With The Decorator
pattern earlier it's I think airflow 2
is where we introduce and I'm really
happy that almost everybody realizes
the data making data as a first-class
citizen within a data orchestrator is a
good thing right so
um so we are all uh we are positive on
the change that airflow has had but we
started with different goals right we
said we want to abstract infrastructure
that's never the goal of airflow we
uh you cannot really
fine-tune a model on airflow out of the
gate like that's one also in flight.org
there are there is a page I can pull it
up here but there's a web page that
compares the two uh we we work with the
airflow ecosystem there's a airflow to
flight operator which we have tried to
Upstream into airflow
Etc it's all available for free we have
companies that use both
and but many companies move over to
using flight exclusively because you
know it solves like the ml part
and the data part in many cases but
certain cases airflow does a good job
and we don't think you have to migrate
away from airflow for like the ETL use
cases so I think airflow is a good fit
there hopefully that answers your
question
hi uh great talk
um I'm trying to still understand
like when you allocate resources let's
say for a task you like say I need like
uh let's say 100 GB of memory or I need
like you know so many cores or whatnot
right uh how does that compare to like
Auto scaling where instead of specifying
it you predefine it here itself right in
terms of like cost versus wastage uh yep
what is better approach
great I think that's a fantastic
question let me repeat the question uh
how like the 100 gigabytes so there are
two parts to this question I would say
uh like when we say declare task
resources like 64 CPUs 100 gigabytes of
RAM how does that happen and does is
there a cost advantage of doing so uh
one is yes it cannot just automatically
happen you need to have resources for
flight ships with like the admin system
itself like the service will not allow
you to create tasks for which the
administrator has not
uh ex like explicitly mentioned that
that is they are supported for example
if you request for 16 gpus there is no
machine in the world that has 16 gpus
today right and and it will it will not
allow you to do that uh right off that
the registration time but if you do
enable it you and you can set these
policies completely on your own
um so for example you can say I do not
want anybody to use more than two gpus
if you do want to use 16 gpus in that
elastic config you can say you can say
nodes equal to two
eight GPU is equal to 8 and then you'll
have 8 and 816 gpus right so that's how
it
second question the benefit of doing
ephemeral infrastructure or static
infrastructure we think there are huge
benefits of doing ephemeral
infrastructure because
the the way
um most machine learning and data
products work is you do not you do not
need a consistently High scale
infrastructure because of Auto scaling
built into the system because we use
kubernetes underneath and the cloud Auto
scalers Etc you scale to zero when
nobody's using it and you scale to the
highest limit when anybody's using it
and with multitens you can actually put
limits on what a particular project
within the flight ecosystem can spend
like for example they can one project
could request only 1000 CPUs and another
project can require 1000 CPUs your total
cluster capacity might be only 1500 CPUs
and that's okay and so the system will
balance between them hopefully that
answers your question and and then using
Spark further reduces the cost so go I
think going to zero actually makes sense
when the the bursty workloads
thanks for the talk
um question on hyper parameter
optimization so in cases where you're
not just trying to explore a fixed set
but like you're doing Bayesian
optimization so you don't you don't know
what the 11th one you want to try is
until you've tried the first 10.
can you talk a little bit about how
that's done in your world yeah so so
flight is an orchestrator that connects
with your infrastructure you have to
remember that for what that means
let me repeat the question also it's
about hyper parameter optimization in
deep learning hyper parameter
optimization is very
kind of crowdsourced like people in the
world are finding the best hyper
parameters but in the in the traditional
world we still do Bayesian optimization
Etc and flight can't handle supplement
some of it using Dynamic workflows you
just saw that but that's never been our
goal we I don't think it's the most
optimal choice for some of it and that's
where we do connect with Ray so you can
use Ray for as a task type you can use
spark as a task type you can use task as
a task type
and and it will spin up the ray cluster
it'll spin up the dash cluster it'll
spin up the spark cluster
it will run locally on on your laptop
and it will run remote as if those
clusters are spin up with your
requirements in and I would recommend
you to check out the website but also
you can use Dynamic workflows we have
seen many people use Dynamic workflows
to actually achieve uh Bayesian optimize
optimization or at least you know grid
search Etc
and it also ships with a thing called as
map task which allows you to Fan out to
thousands of containers at the in
concurrently which is very suitable for
credit search for example
yeah I think we are done with the
questions thank you once again
and thank you thank you for the
presentation and let's head out for the
lunch
thank you so much
[Applause]